Tom Greensted: Hello and welcome.
My name is Tom Greenstedt,
I am the collective product manager for mobile devices
The Guardian. "
I am really aware that I have given the short word
At its closing session today,
So I will limit my words as much as possible, to some extent
You drink a drink.
I'll talk about how
We tried, specifically the application team over the past year,
Provide some new work methods that
Emerging creativity lies in
Development teams themselves.
It seems that the industry in general has taken
A really long time, to be frank, publishing industry,
In particular to accommodate that development
Is a creative process in itself,
And that teams of software developers and designers
They actually have creative ideas.
And that what we bet on is the real attempt to extract this creative energy.
There are now many different ways to free ideas
And try to put features to the public,
There are also many different ways to graphically draw them.
But for the occasion of the purpose of the word
I will draw it graphically on two different axes,
On the X axis, we have
There is a self-generated creativity - ideas
Which you create yourself,
And trying to implement them.
At the other end, we have creativity
The supposed - the things that others give you.
On the Y axis, we have a payoff on business.
So, we have features that are deployed
Ultimately, it will achieve high business value and high value
Users.
It should be noted that these two things
Synonymous, and here we have things of low value,
They are either things that do not appoint anyone
Or which do not benefit the business at all.
So, I will
Highlight some of the different ways we have worked
And how to draw a statement on the two different axes.
Well, what could be a good example of the right upper side?
Well, the strategic features, right?
If they have strategic features, they are
Maybe it is very, very high value
Because they work in parallel with the entire business strategy,
As they are probably, imposed ideas where
The business is required by the team to implement them.
In our case, it may be, team, that we want to
Many more users log in to the app.
So, we get something like unfinished business.
I will now discuss the backlog,
The tendency towards self-innovation to a small extent,
Because software developers, especially those working in flexible teams
They can choose which cards they think
Really important.
But find themselves imposed on them things,
People like me are trying to arrange the backlog.
Then we find bad ideas,
Bad ideas tend to,
Especially from senior management -
I am recognized for this - to impose low-value creativity.
We really need to do this, team.
Crap, it's a failure.
Then we find mistakes and responsibility.
I was trying now to locate a place to put this.
Well, the teams at "The Guardian"
To guide the genuine care of product quality,
So they find individual mistakes,
The individual religion then adds it when they think that
Really important.
These things are of little value individually.
And yet I do not want you to think
I say that quality is not important.
Quite the opposite - quality is crucial.
If we talk about it in general, you might go up there,
But when viewed on an individual basis,
They reflect relatively low quality,
But it is more self-inflicted.
Now, we will move on to talk about innovation days.
Raise your hands if you know what is the day of innovation?
Well, not the big number.
Raise your hands if you already participate in the innovation day?
Well, almost the same number.
Well, innovation day is
Day assembling a large number of developers in a single room,
She says to them, set out and created something new and made an offer in the end.
So it is in some respects the clearest example
For self-generated creativity.
Now, innovation day projects are often very valuable.
In fact, The Guardian has an internal software package
Analytical called Ophan, it's amazing,
It's a great,
It was the product of one of our innovation days.
But often - so it's worth saying
That it should be placed at the top here,
But mostly innovation projects are not arranged
Within strategic objectives
Because it is really an opportunity for software developers
For start and creativity.
Sometimes ideas are great,
But insufficient resources are available to support them,
It can not be implemented because of other things
Conducted by the business.
Sometimes these days are frankly an opportunity for the crowd to entertain.
Sometimes, ideas of innovation days are very, very valuable.
However, innovation days often have low returns
For the long-term value of the business
Now I'm talking about a specific feature,
There are a lot of really good reasons
To hold innovation days - to give an opportunity to software developers
To work together.
It's a really great way to make people who
They do not talk to each other talking.
But if you're only interested in individual features,
The innovation days themselves are not long enough
It is not focused enough to produce consistent returns
Of the business.
So for me, the most important question is, what suits this place?
You can access the way to work
They are of very high value
And liberate the inherent creativity in the development teams,
And are really good returns on business?
For us, the thing that fits this question mark
Is the construction week.
Now the construction week, as you probably guess
It's a bit like a day of innovation but instead of just inventing
Something as fast as you can to view it
To the public, you create it
To the stage where the principle can be tested.
Instead of a day, it is a week.
The reason behind making it a week is to give
Pinch enough for development teams, engineers and UX designers
To create something concrete
Is already convincing.
Like Innovation Day, it frees creativity
By giving them a great deal of self-awareness,
So they choose the thing they start to create.
There are some rules governing it.
The most important thing in this regard to come out with a strategic value,
Is to have a strategic theme.
Well, the weeks we've had over the past year
About monetizing mobile devices,
Innovation in editing, core allocation factors,
Increase application speed and raise responsiveness.
Solutions are not enforced,
The job of someone like me was to reach the subject,
And allow teams as many as possible
Work and come up with the most creative ideas
Emanating from them in an attempt to achieve this.
We were taking time at the beginning of the construction week
To understand deeply what we will try to implement,
The output was in fact testable.
This requires access to
A place where we can get realistic feedback from actual users.
Well, this is an example of our recent construction weeks.
My wonderful team is working on this.
It should be noted that the team is not limited to engineers only,
This is Frank,
It is designed,
We have Sabhagit,
It is a mobile editor.
We have Helen at the top, she's a UX researcher.
When you make weeks of innovation, we try to form a team
As large as possible.
Now, I have mentioned that one of the main things
Is that the output is testable.
I wanted to think a bit
What I mean here.
Since the idea of ​​the creation week
Is to access useful things useful to users.
So what do I mean by testability?
Well, we have a testing hand at UX Lab.
Now, this is great, but what we look forward to from
The build week is access to something
It is tested away from the laboratory.
After that, we have our alpha program.
Now, we're using Alpha on Google Play
To make stand-alone versions of Android apps
Be available to any user
Within "The Guardian."
The alpha program is amazing
To test the stability of the version with 600 users
At the end of the construction week.
It is also a great way to entice stakeholders.
There is no such thing as finding someone
Suddenly a feature did not know they existed
For the first time it meets one of the needs
And hasten their introduction into production.
We also use the beta program.
If you're interested in signing up for the beta program,
You can follow this url at the top.
Beta is running for thousands of Android users,
Usually we get into some of the amazing ideas that are
Resulting in weeks of construction directly to beta.
Or we test MVT and A / B for the first impression of the release
In the immediate environment as well.
But the main point is that we ask for the difference
Spend one week understanding the problem deeply
And access to more creative ideas
To solve and prove
Whether thoughts are successful or not.
[INAUDIBLE] Prove?
Is this really demonstrable?
Do I have examples where this worked?
When you combine these slides together,
Someone called me from Google
To ask about content, should not it be "likely?"
I replied, no, no, it was "demonstrable".
This is a clear.
Well, what are some examples - to stamp out -
Which helped the construction weeks "The Guardian"?
Well, the first thing was the Hide Ads button.
If you look at ads
On the right side here,
There is a lovely little button to hide.
Was the product of the mobile monetization week,
It leads users to a paid subscription to our free application.
Now, when the developers reach
To this, seemed a good idea, but given
The internal controversy is fully appreciated
Inside "The Guardian," we never reached a stage
This feature is actually released,
Ads are conflicting with subscriptions
In the app, they are different revenue providers.
As a result of creating this feature within the build week,
We had the opportunity to test them really quickly
And access to discussions
About if the idea was good in the shadow
The existence of real statistical data predicting the decision.
As you can guess, if you use an Android app,
The decision to publish the button was in the application, so we did this
There has been a significant increase in the rate of conversion to contributions.
Search and Profile - [INAUDIBLE]
From customization to each of your reading records,
This was not available, and a developer was created
This beautiful collection of profile and search.
She entered the UX lab directly, and received a great deal of admiration
We published it in three weeks, I think.
It's another type of feature
Which showed real benefits to users
Who look forward to returning to articles that
They have already read it.
what is next?
In the relevant construction week of the assignment
A member of the developer team met
With a service developer
They created a new recommendation engine,
Which we will most likely call Discover.
It has not yet been put out but it is likely
His appearance this quarter of the year.
This type of investment is what business activity is
As a whole to run out if done
Insert its creation into the strategy
From the beginning.
But due to its beginnings in the construction week
We had the opportunity to test it very quickly
To enter it into the alpha program.
Similarly, it uses the Read It To Me application - Read It To Me
Text-to-speech engine in Android
To allow you to use any part of the content of "Guardian"
Without a screen.
It's great that it was in the construction week we held last week
It works not only on your phone but also on Wear
Now, it works with audio files.
This is another application of "The Guardian" as a whole
To get out probably more spontaneously
Where we focused on the written word
Which can be fully understood.
But by adding editorial innovation
To be the theme of the construction week for our engineers,
We have already had the advantage
To increase participation significantly,
We are happy.
This is my happy team,
Well, what advice do I suggest to you here?
If you have had weeks of innovation, they are astonished.
I say to those of you who develop from top to bottom,
Which is sometimes required and necessary,
There is an amazing middle ground.
This is the middle ground to explain the problem well
And give the teams the opportunity to start
Design and testing solutions.
Well, if you do not underestimate this,
Try it at least once
You will see the result, and you will be surprised
Delightfully. thank you very much.